alors bonjour grégory effectivement ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que tout se
joue dans les murs de la ville à la
grange qui se situe à quelques centaines
de mètres d'ici alors effectivement vous
le disiez il ya du une première réunion
en comité restreint et puis une deuxième
réunion comité élargi c'est à dire avec
les délégations alors au coeur des
échanges et bien la situation en ukraine
la situation dans le haut-karabagh
également la situation dans la péninsule
coréenne aussi mais également la
situation au moyen-orient plus
précisément la libye l'irak ou encore la
syrie et on en parlait justement avec
notre invité qui nous a rejoint ici à
genève
riadh sidaoui bonjour un jour alors vous
êtes directeur du centre arabe des
analyses politiques et sociales à genève
alors je le disais dans le coeur des
discussions à la situation au
moyen-orient
qu'est-ce qu'on peut s'attendre au tour
de deux de ces échanges entre vladimir
poutine et joe biden sur le moyen-orient
il faut dire que la mission a été
accomplie les jeux sont faits en moyen
orient surtout en syrie
nous savons aujourd'hui qu'il y avait un
plomb d'éliminer le régime laïc c'est
rien c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est l'ex
ministre des affaires étrangères
français roland dumas
elle a dit j'étais à londres deux ans
avant la crise syrienne
mes homologues anglais le mans 10 ans
prépare un plan afin de déstabiliser et
les miss élues miss au régime laïque
l'intervention russe en syrie une
intervention légitime et légal pourquoi
parce que le régime syrien est un
le gouvernement serviette un
gouvernement souverain membre de l'onu a
demandé l'aide à na li avec des accords
nationaux et des accords internationaux
donc c'est légal or la présence d des
terroristes et des milices qui sont ce
qu'ils sont subventionnés qui sont
financés aujourd'hui on ça vient pas le
qatar et l'arabie saoudite l'oci c'est
même je baille de nous
on dit zhao baige a dit devant les
étudiants de l'université a 20 ans quand
elle était vice président qu'elle a dit
nos amis saoudiens qatarienne est notre
ami hardinghen tueur ils ont financé les
groupes terroristes en syrie je vous
invite à vous tourner vers la caméra il
ya également la situation en libye
qu'est ce que peuvent se dire les deux
hommes cet après-midi sur la situation
très chaotique ont servi la libye aussi
c'est la responsabilité de l'otan en
2011 le temps quand elle était revenue à
via la résolution du conseil sécurité
1973 et qui dit juste l'instauration
d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne pas plus
mais c'est devenu quoi détruire un
régime
et l état se voit que l'état libyen
depuis 2011 notant a cassé à la fois le
régime le gouvernement l etat donc on
n'a pas une et en libye il n'y a pas un
état qui à l'état ne jouit pas de du
monopole de la violence légitime comme
il disait
max weber les russes sont intervenus
aussi avec leurs alliés historiques ce
qui reste de l'armée libyenne à l'est
les américains ont envoyé les troupes
turques d'art dogan art de gagner les
membres est latent piste un membre très
actif au sein de nos temps donc c'est le
chaos qui règne et le peuple libyen qui
paie toujours cette facture lourde
pourquoi parce qu'on a cassé son état en
2000 ans
il ya aussi l'afghanistan c'est prévu 1
que les deux hommes échangent as à ce
sujet là qu'ils vont pouvoir a là encore
se dire au sujet de l'afghanistan
l'afghanistan est très très proche
évidemment de la russie beaucoup plus
proche que les états unis d'amérique
la russie qui a arrêté les niveaux
soviétique l'union soviétique a eu une
très mauvaise expérience en afghanistan
les américains n'ont pas tiré les leçons
n'ont pas compris qu'ils ne peuvent pas
dominer des tribus qui sont et qui sont
des guerriers par nature donc il ya un
peu une défaite militaire américaine
puisque les troupes américaines vont se
retirer de gagner ce taux est je pense
que peut-il et la russie en ont beaucoup
d'expérience en afghanistan elles
peuvent donner des vrais conseils aux
états unis
d'amérique alors peut-être cette
dernière question il ya un troisième
acteur finalement aujourd'hui c'est
genève qui accueille cette rencontre
vous êtes ici vous à genève
finalement quelles conséquences pour la
suisse aujourd'hui cette rencontre entre
américains et russes
le monde entier a les yeux rivés vers
genève aujourd'hui c'est bien puisque je
porte la nationalité de genève et des de
l'a6 on l'appelle l'état et la
république de genève
elle a toujours joué genève un rôle de
neutralité comme le monde a des
problèmes quand il ya à genève c'est
trouver des solutions ça me rappelle les
accords historiques entre les
révolutionnaires algériens et français
en 1962 aussi la guerre du vietnam
aussi les conflits conflit entre l'iran
et les états unis d'amérique
tous les problèmes du monde c'est genève
qui c'est de participer de trouver des
solutions pacifiques et durables
merci beaucoup riadh sidaoui d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
depuis je nage je le rappelle vous êtes
le directeur du centre arabe des
analyses politiques et sociales voilà à
grégory alors alors en tout cas est bien
la réunion en forme élargie ans poursuit
ici à genève
vladimir poutine doit donner une
conférence de presse à l'issue on
l'annoncent à 18 heures on verra bien ça
peut bouger en tout cas joe biden lui
s'exprimera par la suite pas de
conférence de presse commune donc on
attend à les déclarations l'une après
l'autre des deux hommes ici à genève
gregory merci aux lignes de car en fait